وقبيل صلاه الفجر اعتدت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على عدد من الفلسطينيين عند
باب الاسباط ومناعتهم بالقوه من دخول
المسجد الاقصى لاداء صلاه الفجر كما منعت
قوه الاحتلال عشره النساء من الدخول الى
المسجد
وقد اغلق عشرات الفلسطينيين ابواب المصلى
القبلي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك من
الداخل قبل انتهاء صلاه التراويح واكد
المعتكفون انهم اغلقوا الابواب للحيلوله
دون تمكن قوه الاحتلال من اقتحام المسجد
واخراجهم بالقوه وكان الاردن قد رفض تسلم
رساله رسميه من اسرائيل تطالب بالضغط على
الاوقاف الاسلاميه لاخراج المعتكفين الذين
وصفتهم
بالارهابيين في هذه الاثناء اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي تمديد الاغلاق في الضفه
الغربيه وغزه حتى منتصف ليل الاربعاء
المقبل بناء على تقييم الوضع
الاسرائيلي يعاف جلند قال انه ازرع اوامر
لاتخاذ خطوات ثوريه في اعقاب الهجمات
الارهابيه على حد تعبيله واعلن غالنت في
تغريده ان الجيش سيدعم وحده الشرطه حيثما
كان الامر ضروريا كما امر باستدعاء اربع
سرايا احتياط من حرس الحدود
من باب السلسله في بلده القديمه في القدس
المحتله تنضم الى مراسله الجزيره نجوى اذن
صباح غير عادي توتر واقتحامات وايضا منع
المصلين باداء صلاه الفجر كيف هو المشهد
الان في هذه اللحظه
نعم دعني ابدا
من الذين نتواجد به هذا هو باب السلسله
احد ابواب المسجد الاقصى المبارك منه يخرج
المستوطنون والمتطرفون اليهود بعد انتهاء
الاقتحامات التي ينفذونها في هذه الساعه
بعد قليل سيغلق باب المغاربه وهو الباب
المخصص لهذه الاقتحامات من قبل شرطه
الاحتلال التي تؤمن هذه الاقتحامات بدءا
من باب المغاربه الملاصق لحائط البراق
وصولا الى هذا الباب باب السلسله وهو
الاقرب عمليا لحائط البراق ايضا بعد
اتمامهم للاقتحام الذي يكون على شكل جوله
دائريه بمحاذاه الاسوار الداخليه للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك وصولا الى هنا وبعدها
يخرجون اعداد كبيره منذ هذا الصباح
رايناها تخرج ضمن مجموعات بعد ان اقتحمت
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وفقه دائره الاوقاف
الاسلاميه بلغ عدد المستوطنين والمتطرفين
الذين اقتحموا هذا اليوم في رابع ايام عيد
الفصح اليهودي نحو 800 مقتحم بحمايه كبيره
من شرطه الاحتلال وعلى عده مجموعات وصلت
الى تسعه عشره مجموعه من هنا كما نشاهد
عبر عدسه الكاميرا يواصل
المستوطنون طريقهم الى منطقه حائط البراق
حيث يتم في هذه الاثناء اداء ما يسمى
لديهم بصلاه بركه الكهنه في ايام عيد
الفصح هناك في باحه حائط البراق وهو
الحائط الغربي للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
والذي يطلق عليه الاسرائيليون حائط المبكى
تقوم حاليا صلاه بركه الكهنه ويشارك بها
الاف الاسرائي من اجل تامين هذه الصلاه تم
حشد
اعداد كبيره من شرطه الاحتلال وحرس الحدود
تنتشر في مناطق مختلفه في عده حلقات سواء
كان في محيط البلده القديمه في ازقه
البلده القديمه وايضا في محيط حائط البراق
وفي محيط المسجد الاقصى المبارك هناك
تواجد كبير للشرطه شهدناه منذ صباح هذا
اليوم في اعداد كبيره وفي مواقع مختلفه
وكانت الشرطه قد اعلنت قبل
قبل الليله الماضي عن استعداداتها
وتجهيزاتها لتامين صلاه الصلاه
للاسرائيليين هذا اليوم
بحشد اربع سرايا من حرس الحدود من قوات
الاحتياط في حرس الحدود التابعه لشرطه
الاحتلال لتضاف الى سته سرايا اخرى تم
حجدها منذ بدايه شهر رمضان
المبارك مع الابقاء على باقي قوات
الاحتياط في حرس الحدود في حاله تاهب
واستعداد وفقا ايضا لاوامر صدرت عن رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو اذا هو هي حاله
من الهدوء الحذر جدا في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك لكن فقط اسمحوا لي ان اشير هذه
حاله الهدوء هي ناتجه عن عدم تفريغ المسجد
الاقصى المبارك من قبل شرطه الاحتلال من
المصلين المسلمين وهذا يبدو بعض الضغوط
التي مورست على اسرائيل في اعقاب الصور
التي صدرت الاسبوع الماضي من الاعتداء
الكبير الذي يصفه الفلسطينيون بالهمج
والوحش على المصلين في داخل المسجد القبلي
وتحديدا هذه الضغوط اتت من الاردن التي
تعتبر صاحبه الوصايه على المقدسات
الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في المسجد الاقصى
ورفض ورفضه للتعامل مع رساله اسرائيليه
وصفت المعتكفين بانهم على لسان وزاره
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه بانهم ارهابيين
وبالتالي من الواضح ان هذه الاجراءات
اليوم تاتي بقرار من شرطه الاحتلال وهذا
يؤكد المؤكد ربما بان حاله الهدوء
والتصعيد من يتحمل
مسؤوليتها هم الاحتلال فقط شكرا لك
نجوانهم مراسله الجزيره من باب السلسله في
بلده القديمه في القدس المحتله